hey Johnny Johnny what the other day I
went up to my girlfriend I said you know
I like a little [ __ ] as I said yeah
yeah me too
mine's as big as a house what now now
the guy who said that joke in the in the
first movies writing and directing this
one oh good the final trailer for the
Predators here yay actually put out a
tweet the other day that I'm weirdly
excited for this movie guys I want to
say thank you to everyone who's been
joining our patron page this past month
we do full like TV show reactions and
weekly Q&A s TV shows that we cover
attack on Titan and my hero academia
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
Riverdale Gotham and just started up
supernatural I want to give a patron to
the day shout out to a man named Mikhail
Linden this man is from Sweden and I
constantly bring that up but there's
something else I got to bring up today I
wanted to shout him out on the predator
video because if there's one guy at our
patreon who totally gives off creepy
predator vibes
it's Mikhail's mother Kayla's mom needs
to be arrested as soon as possible
seriously if anyone hears from Sweden
and knows of a man named Mikael and it's
not a common Swedish name you gotta find
this dude's mom arrest her right away
she's the one who wrote that let's eat
joke for the predator movie she needs to
be put down immediately
yeah color humor must be stopped but no
seriously Mikael thanks for being a part
of our page buddy you're a great guy
you sound like like the mercenary who
would show up in a predator movie don't
completely debunk my my show I'm sorry
it's false
there's any funny jokes in this trailer
I'm just gonna laugh like Billy from the
first moon
logo let me guess he's done something
crazy crazy as this moves to kill money
[Music]
aliens
but its weakness
[Music]
[Music]
what house
oh damn they saved their best trailer
for last yeah trailer looks fun those F
em up moments yeah no I decided sense
for my sellout every moment I actually
watched the first predator last night
the predator franchise has really
changed a lot since that first movie
when you're seeing the violence here I
love you like what hey there he is
yeah yeah you know it's just like a real
[ __ ] yeah like it's savage in the way
they're doing it destroying them you
know it feels like a like a really
snappy piece of fanfic to me yeah as
opposed to you know the hunt is on and
then the Predators collecting human
trophies and stuff yeah that'll get that
vibe here whatsoever I get a vibe oh
this is it anihilation is happening
right here yeah yeah yeah I mean it
doesn't seem like they're de protein
this with too much like reverence fella
we have to uphold yeah seems like
they're just gonna have a blast you know
splattering you know mercenaries yeah
like that having carnage on screen this
gave me the thing I've been kind of
complaining about from the other trailer
so I'm like you keep saying this is a
shame Black's movie where's the shame
black humor and I finally got a sense of
its humor throughout most of this
trailer yeah you could see from the cast
of characters bringing it back to these
like soldier mercenary types I think is
a really cool idea because in the way
that does actually harken back to the
original predator because and the first
one you know this the soldiers in there
they're a rescue team but they're
Expendables and then here you know these
guys are prisoners mercenaries so when
they're gonna be our heroes they're also
like expendable like soldiers as well
you know rough do ya they die your
lifestyle and the government can feel
that way about them too having soldiers
who are kind of have a you know crazy
sense of humor about the world I wrote
to my girlfriend said jeez you got a big
[ __ ]
jeez II got a big [ __ ] she said why did
you say that twice I said I did it
same black kind of humor along the tone
of the humor felt often the other
trailers they felt like weirdly out of
place if actually if your mom's vagina
were a video game to be rated E for
Everyone here the humor actually made
sense I don't notice cuz they had like
this rap music going over the humor
actually fit well in terms of like who
the characters were all the predator
designs I think look really cool you
mean you got the og predator you got the
new savage looking predator you got
predator dogs in here yeah I mean this
definitely looks like it'll give you the
meat and potatoes of what you want out
of a predator movie I mean I got a lot
of better sense for the ensemble vibe
anyway like I'm not who everybody is
which is like what the vibe between
everybody might be a good sense for what
the voice you know the Shane Black voice
the movies gonna be and then just how
much cool ass action we're gonna get the
insolvable OTT of fun this time around
especially keegan-michael Greyjoy gonna
die do they just give that away with you
know usually when the predator locks
target on you like that that means
you're dead people won't care if they
know Theon dies they're in the house
Olivia Munn he's not in there it seems
like he's not with the group for a lot
of this movie money less that's a
mislead and then like the target goes up
and then we cut away and we think he's
dead but then like much later into the
film he comes back and saved somebody in
the vendée yes they said Jake Busey is
in this movie and he was even in
interviews there's some on Conan and
talking about being in this view is
supposed to play Gary Busey son from the
second predator maybe he'll just feel
unseen well I'm hoping that certain link
a brad ursin
Glover's son oh hey and then Thomas Jane
is Arnold yeah definitely that's the way
yeah and then olivia munn is sylvester
stallone's dog for no reason
oh you know I mean I bet some of these
people were descended from the wonderful
cast of characters from the - AVP movies
as well maybe oh yeah I guess my last
note of why I really like this trailer
one might interpret this trailer as oh
it's just cool edited trailer but I
don't think it is to me this seems like
the trailer that actually might
represent the tone of this movie where
the other ones were like is this the
exactly the other ones always seemed off
to me about what they were going for
this is the only one that I've seen so
far word like this actually seems like
this was more along the lines of what
the movie will feel like yeah I mean
this pitched me a movie that feels like
it's gonna have a lot of coolness to it
a lot of attitude and a lot of snappy
rhythm and whatnot and I feel like the
other shows maybe trying to pitch it as
more of something intense and yeah like
do you feel like a seriously mercenaries
together I'm like what my theory is
the test screenings of way back when for
this movie there was a real divide with
how this film had a lot of humor and
then I think when they did the trailer
they were trying to hide that but you
know if you keep slapping shame blacks
name on it you gotta have rope with it
you know you iron they've got a bunch of
mercenaries and then pretty like ya
bunch of prisoners here yeah alright
guys well did you get your tickets for
the predator geez you got a big ok did
you get your tickets we got ours IMAX
Universal that Thursday night showing go
meet up with us I know you won't
no one does you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and check us out on patreon we got
full like TV show reactions weekly Q&A
it's my birthday on Monday so I might be
away from the internet bye